it's a tremendous impact actually that
I'm seeing through Khan Academy the most
impact I see are for those kids who
really need the challenge and I also see
the spark in the kids who've struggled
who in a whole group math lesson can
appear to be lost and then shy and then
try to hide and now they can hide behind
their computer screen so to speak and
continue to work at their own pace a lot
of students are very cognizant of where
they are in relation to their peers some
of them won't want to appear smarter
some won't want to appear slower but
those students will hesitate to ask
questions they just want to be right
there in the middle teaching to the
middle only does the middle good and you
see it seems like you're leaving out
two-thirds of the class that way and so
there has to be a better way to do it
Khan Academy offers an assessment piece
that's incredible it's so right they're
an immediate it's a quick picture of
where students are at where they are
having issues where their struggles are
so I know who I need to visit with and
where I can help them where I can come
alongside and remediate and support and
they love those aha moments where they
can be the teacher and they can tell me
about something that they think I don't
know how to do my students select weekly
goals for themselves based on their own
data so I have them looking at their own
data now in a graphic way they're able
to visualize in a very concrete way
their progress you know usually you just
moved through a math classroom it's like
okay yeah we finish this chapter we
finish that book but the kids don't
really see everything that they've
accomplished and this lets them see it
and it makes it real for them and then
at that point I was excited for my kids
because I saw that again as being a tool
for them that ultimately would help them
become responsible for their own
learning and deciding hey this is where
I need work the kids are enjoying it
because it's very engaging for them I'm
enjoying it because my kids do my
students do kids go home excited about
math and that's what parents see they
see that kids are talking about math
they're discussing what they did in
class they're showing them something on
the computer that they just learned how
to do parents know their kids better
than anyone so they can encounter a Khan
Academy problem if they're working
through it with their child they can say
hey remember when we were at the bee
and we did this and this is what was
involved and so they can really help me
tie these new concepts to previous
learning if they get involved with their
kids with the Khan Academy at home meth
I always found after teaching for 21
years kids love it or kids don't or
don't love it and now I think I've got
27 kids in my class who could at some
point during the day say hey I love math
you